well then what are the top five
screenwriters that someone should study
I mean if they need to know how I'm
going back to well if you go to if you
go to the you know the 101 habits book
so there's all the 14 of the top writers
recommend that you can see their work
and and the new version of the book the
10th anniversary edition had eight new
writers Tony Gilroy and Terry Rossi owns
both big names so between the two you
have 22 writers who are your mentors in
their advice to you in terms of writers
that Meyer of course Pixar except
storytellers so Brad Bird and John
Lasseter
the things John Lasseter - which is
really interesting just to show you the
power that he had it's a storyteller
when Disney bought Pixar and John
Lasseter became the head of animation
all the Disney Animation movies have
been successful like really great
storytelling start with bolt all the way
to tangled frozen even the lace delays
one Zootopia so these are not Pixar
movies but you can see the Pixar touch
in that in them and they've been
successful with audiences so kind of
shows you that he's had quite an
influence on Disney so yeah I admire him
you know hundreds and hundreds of
writers um well for you let's say you
were in you know high school or
something college right what were some
green plays that were you like I've just
got to do something like this right well
for me it was mostly genre so you know
always my favorite genres always been I
was going to sci-fi person so I mostly
specifically futuristic as opposed to
sci-fi I like to make that distinction
futuristic is more like in the future
but on earth as opposed to Star Trek
Star Wars even though I love Star Wars
you know spaceships in space I think -
so I tend to gravitate more towards we
thought-provoking stories like Blade
Runner
The Matrix
inception anything that that really has
a really thought-provoking concept and
story taking place on earth in the
future Eternal Sunshine of the spotless
mind is a favorite of mine so yeah any
thought-provoking movie attenti like
some Mars futuristic thrillers I still
remember the day I saw signs of the
Lambs so an advanced screening of tons
of the Lambs and it was the very first
movie where I totally was not aware of
anything else like I remember the lights
went down in you watch the movie and the
next thing I knew was the lights coming
out it's like my god I just two hours
went by and I was completely mesmerized
from beginning to end every second
that's never happened before in a movie
that was the first time I remember being
so taken and engaged by a movie what do
you think it was aside from just great
scratches on the restroom ship yeah just
amazing like everything everything about
an interesting story compelling
characters great relationships just
fantastic twists and cleverness and
caring about not only the main character
but caring about the villain amuses just
great craftsmanship I mean kudos to
Thomas Harris who wrote the book was
very close to them to the to the movie
and to Ted towel you wrote the script
the screenplay and Jonathan Demme II who
direct I mean this was one of the very
few movies that got that swept the the
top five Oscars you know you have the
best best movie Best Director Best
Screenplay Best Actor Best Actress
they haven't been that many movies in
the history of movies that got those
five to consider the pantheon of movies
so you have like I mean the first one
was it happened one night with Clark
Gable and Claudette Colbert
I was not another favorite of mine I'm
not sure if I believe One Flew the
Cuckoo's Nest also was one of the top
top five Awards I'm not mistaken but
Sansa diamonds was the last one I think
ya have to research that but I remember
I mean I knew from the I wasn't advanced
screening so it was before it opened and
I was like oh my god
if anybody else has the same experience
I've had this move this move is going to
be great classic sweep the Oscars I mean
everything and and I was rooting for
that film you know I remember watching
the Oscars when when that happened and
just being Wow yeah one of my hometown
favorites and I'm blind blade blade
runner it's one of my top favorites
although that didn't do as well when it
when it opened and like bother about it
was actually considered a flop and only
became a classic through through
word-of-mouth and just the sheer visual
will of the story that's an interesting
concept when when something doesn't show
the numbers but then there's this cold
oh yeah yeah it's quite a few movies
like that shank redemption is another
one that that kind of flopped open the
you know box office but then created you
know life of its own just from the sheer
you know audience you know it's like wow
but they responded to it what about
that's just a most other thing is
probably about concept I mean you know
when you look at the concept of
Shawshank Redemption there's nothing
appealing about it right I mean the good
is a movie about you know two people in
prison you know okay but when you
experience it and this is something to a
lesson for writers is that just because
you don't have a high concept now if
you're a beginning writer high concept
is paramount it helps you because it
helps you break in because you will get
your script will be requested and then
once they get the script in from them
and if it's well executed then you're
here on your way in but so I don't
recommend having low concepts when
you're a beginner but in this case I
mean it was Frank Darabont it was
Stephen Stephen King's novella so but it
was it was a low concept there was
nothing about the concept that made it
appealing so I didn't really drive
audiences to the theaters at the time
but the execution is masterful and so
that's what once you're in there once
you're in the door and you experience it
then you go my god and then you tell
others and where the mouse that's how it
happens you know so that's the case with
with that
you